every time anyone pays for anything
there's going to be an extra cost
involved there isn't the single currency
other than Bitcoin that has done
anything that Bitcoin can do there is no
way that you will ever have the speed of
final settlement with Bitcoin or the low
expensive accomplishing it then you can
have today with all kinds of other
monies compared to the real alternatives
that exist today Bitcoin is the only one
the only one that offers is the chance
of having a monetary system free of
government control about a third of all
Bitcoin exchanges have been hacked at
one time or another that's in comparison
to about 1% of banks all of the people
that are just constantly finding
problems with Bitcoin need to just come
to peace with it this is your only
alternative to central bank's deal with
it
we now have to segue into the main event
which is the debate on the resolution
Bitcoin is poorly suited to the purpose
of becoming any nation's main medium of
exchange arguing for the affirmative
george Celgene george please come to the
stage arguing for the negative 70 and
safe at the end a moose safe please come
to the stage 15 minutes to establish the
affirmative for the resolution Jane
please close the voting Thank You Jean
thank you all for giving me this
opportunity to try to convince you that
Bitcoin isn't quite as greatest you
think I want to start out by saying that
this is important
I'm not against Bitcoin I'm pointing
this out because I think it was late
last week somebody on Twitter said oh I
didn't know
Celgene was against Bitcoin and I
tweeted back I said not against Bitcoin
I'm actually quite keen on Bitcoin in
many respects I think it's a wonderful
development and it's assuring in a whole
set of technological possibilities that
that I regard is extremely important and
intriguing and I and in fact years ago
before many economists were writing
about this stuff I wrote an article
about why I thought cryptocurrencies
generally not Bitcoin specifically
offered some possibilities for monetary
reform that that were unprecedented and
potentially the best some of the best
possibilities we've seen yet and I'm not
an apologist for official monies I want
you to know that too because I'm about
to claim that it's very unlikely think
practically impossible that bit
we'll take over from any established
official money but that's not because I
like official monies I've written most
of my career against government
monopolies of money and I favor
privatization I'd like to see money
privatized it's just that I don't think
bitcoin is cut out for the job and
that's the argument I have to make today
I want to start by pointing out that
it's an uphill battle for any new
upstart money to replace to set aside an
incumbent money to to to win people over
from that incumbent money and that's
because money is a network good it's
perhaps the most clear-cut case of a
network good out there what's a network
good it's a good where the usefulness of
the good to anybody is a function of how
many other people are using it and money
is a is a classic network good in that
sense the first question a person asks
about whether to use a money or not
whether it's a good money is whether
they can where is what can i buy with
this stuff how many people will take it
in exchange for things they have to sell
that's the first thing that people want
to know about any money and of course if
you have an established incumbent money
someplace then that's the stuff
everybody is willing to trade for and it
is disadvantageous to put it mildly to
try to use something else anyone who's
ever traveled knows that if you go to
another country and you whip out your
dollars
you found it suddenly discovered that in
most cases not in all because the dollar
is one of the more widely used monies
that your dollars aren't particularly
valuable in other parts of the world and
certainly true for Bitcoin that bitcoin
is not widely used anywhere
and in the world though it is used to
some extent so I come to the proposition
that's going to inform the rest of my
remarks this evening and that is simply
this that a necessary condition for an
upstart money to succeed in replacing an
established incumbent money is that it
has to be considerably more attractive
than that incumbent it has to be so
attractive that it's able to overcome
the fact that the incumbent money is
already widely accepted has a big
network compared to the upstart so you
have to have a lot of attractive
features and in that case the more
attractive money can gain not only
gained a footnote foothold but can
acquire over time a successful network a
network that grows so big that it can
displace the established money so what I
want to do in the remainder of my time
is to talk about the features of Bitcoin
and asks just how attractive is Bitcoin
is it attractive in enough ways to give
it a chance to take over from an
established money if that money is
relatively unattractive in some ways so
let's talk about it I want to start with
the question of trust trust I think is
one of the things that makes Bitcoin
attractive what I mean by trust here is
one particular thing either we can hash
it out in other ways but the sense in
which Bitcoin is attractive with respect
to trust is that there's no central
authority that can suddenly create
doodles of the stuff you all know I'm
sure that there will be a maximum of
approximately 21 million bitcoins issued
ever that they we have a supply that
grows according to a more or less preset
schedule and that will asymptotically
reach that amount and that's that this
means that you don't have to worry about
somebody
pushing a bit point coin button
somewhere where it's going to be 40
million or a hundred million or some
large amount whereas with government
money issuers there is some risk no
doubt that they could abuse their powers
of money creation and course in some
famous cases they either have done it or
are doing it and make their money's
worthless as a result so this is a
respect in which Bitcoin I think
deserves a very high grade let's give it
an a and must be said however that that
many currencies in the world are not
hyper inflating and that indeed if
there's a problem with currencies around
the world today in many cases it's that
at least as far as there are issuing
authorities are concerned they're not
losing value quite quickly enough now
I'll come back to the basket cases
toward the end of my remarks and talk
about why even in those risk in those
cases I don't think bitcoin is likely to
take over but I'm gonna save that for
later so on the question of trust
bitcoin earns a high grade it earns a
high grade on privacy it's not quite
anonymous as you know it's pseudonymous
it gives people the ability to transact
with an identity that is their own
secret as it were and they can
accomplish transactions with this
pseudonym instead of having records that
actually name them and they're allow
people to find out what they've been up
to this privacy acts aspect of Bitcoin
deserves an a- for the simple reason
that it isn't all that hard I'm told for
people to find out through tracing
different transactions to sometimes
place names on to name the people who
are transacting in Bitcoin to discover
who they are as a result of a little bit
of detective work but still it's not bad
but now we come to some other features
of Bitcoin that I think make it
highly unattractive at least to the
average person one of these is
vulnerability to hacking here I'd give
Bitcoin a c-minus or a D I think it's
correct to say that about a third of all
Bitcoin exchanges have been hacked at
one time or another that's in comparison
to about 1% of banks having been hacked
I think that's for this country I don't
know the worldwide figures the truth is
a lot of money something approaching two
billion dollars worth two billion
dollars has been stolen and in Bitcoin
that's quite a large percentage of the
total so safety from hacking theft if
you like not a very good score next
let's take up value volatility things
are getting worse people when they deal
with a medium of exchange don't want
it's to be risky for a very good reason
a lot of us like to take risks but we
like to do it on purpose we don't like
the stuff that we passively receive in
payments to be risky that means we have
to go out of our way to avoid risk by
investing it in something else
and any amount that we keep on hand for
exchange purposes is subject to big
changes in value I know that I don't
want the value of my money holdings to
change dramatically while I decide where
to go shopping or what investments to
make on value volatility Bitcoin
definitely earns an F most monetary
economists will tell you that for the
same reason gold is a very poor medium
exchange its value is highly volatile it
bounces around a great deal yet if you
look at the standard deviation of value
changes in Bitcoin they're about seven
times as great that standard deviation
is about seven times as great that of
gold so this is a highly volatile medium
of exchange or potential medium of
exchange and that makes it quite
unattractive now I'm going to come to
the line
point which is the cost of transacting
or if you like the speed of transacting
there these are related and here Bitcoin
rates definitely a D to an F something
like that it's it's notoriously
non-scalable that means that in practice
small transactions can be very very
expensive for very large transactions
it's not such a big problem there was
something called the transactions crisis
transactions fee crisis back in late
2017 during which it could cost anywhere
from twenty to forty five bucks just to
transfer any amount of Bitcoin any
amount that's a fixed fee today it's
much better but it's widely recognized
in the Bitcoin community that the
transactions fees are not competitive
with other established monies just today
I've been right lately I've been writing
about dollar transfers and now it's
possible to have instantaneous dollar
transfers for basically for nothing a
few pennies if that on all kinds of
networks and that's only going to
increase whereas with Bitcoin if you
want an instant transaction it's going
to cost you and that means every time
anyone pays for anything there's going
to be an extra cost involved now it's
true that there are attempts to reduce
this cost particularly the Lightning
Network is is mentioned as one attempt
to overcome the transaction costs of
Bitcoin but it's still not clear that
that will succeed and it involves at
very least a second layer of
transactions where the whole element of
trust that is one of the key attractive
features of Bitcoin now you have you
have to rely on a centralized party to
handle these transactions which are done
off the chain so to speak and even so it
doesn't work so well when you have non
repeat transactions so now these are
all reasons why Bitcoin is unlikely to
be as popular with the average person as
it is with many people in this room and
this is the average person's willingness
to use Bitcoin is an everyday medium of
exchange that matters for its being able
to take over an incumbent currency
anywhere now having said that I have to
say that it's true that in some
countries not here not now but in some
countries the incumbent currencies are
terrible they're hyper inflating they're
losing value very quickly they impose
costs on their people the people who use
them that are such as could make a
currency like Bitcoin seem relatively
attractive in that case we could say in
those cases that Bitcoin does meet the
necessary conditions that the necessary
conditions for it to take over are met
but those conditions aren't sufficient
and here we come to the other part of
the equation because even though Bitcoin
might be more attractive than some
incumbent currencies before people
turned to Bitcoin they have many other
options they could consider that could
still be more attractive than Bitcoin
they could turn to the dollar they could
turn to the euro they could turn to any
number of alternative means of payment
that would make Bitcoin belong far down
the list of prospective rivals so it's
not just the case that Bitcoin has to be
more attractive than an established
currency it has to be more attractive
than any number of alternative
currencies that could be adopted instead
of Bitcoin and that also have like the
US dollar very large established
networks around the world so for all of
these reasons I think the likelihood of
Bitcoin ever becoming any nation's main
medium of exchange is vanishingly small
I want to end with one final point among
these other curve
that could be more attractive than
Bitcoin and might have a better chance
of becoming a nation's money than it
does I would name other perspective
cryptocurrencies ice I think it's still
a very early stage in the world of
cryptocurrency in the in the story of
cryptocurrency development and some of
these other cryptocurrencies avoid the
flaws of Bitcoin that make it a poor
candidate thank you very much
[Applause]
okay thank you very much first of all to
the Silva forum for the invitation and
for the opportunity to speak here today
thank you very much for professor
Celgene for his comments I'm gonna get
to the meat of it I guess
straight away the I think the key thing
to keep in mind is that bitcoin is
already working Bitcoin is functional
it's been operating non-stop for
practically ten years and it is already
I don't I don't remember the exact
number right now but it is already one
of the top 20 largest valued currencies
in the world so it's already bigger than
many currencies of many other nation
states and most importantly in its
functional role right now Bitcoin is the
only working alternative to central
banks in other words if you'd like to
send money from here to China your only
option up until the year 2008 was to go
through the central bank now after
Bitcoin was invented you are able to do
it with the press of a button in an
automatic way that doesn't rely on
anybody else in the same way that when
you call somebody you know you just
press a bunch of buttons but there's
nobody needed to let the call go through
it's become a mechanical electronic
process that takes you know that happens
because machines do it and it's not
because people intermediated so Bitcoin
is already allowing for transfers across
international borders and it's already
breaking central bank's monopoly over
that so I think the notion that Bitcoin
has been failing I think is completely
unrealistic or the notion of bitcoins
likelihood of succeeding has been
declining and is vanishingly small I
think is contrary to reality because in
reality we see that Bitcoin has been
growing non-stop over the last 10 years
and if you've looked at the growth rate
and you think that oh Bitcoin hasn't
grown fast enough over the last ten
years clearly you haven't looked at the
growth rate it couldn't possibly have
grown and if I mean it could but it's
been an enormous ly fast growth rate and
the notion that we could get a monetary
system and this is really I think the
main problem with Professor surgeons
comments the idea that Bitcoin has to
basically be born ready to handle
everybody's transactions overnight and
to have all of the world's liquidity
handed to it overnight from its creation
or else it has failed I
that is a completely unrealistic way of
assessing it between has been growing in
every metric that matters and bitcoins
been improving in every metric that
matters and there are simply no
objectionable reasons why you would say
that bitcoin cannot work as a monetary
system and so to get to the point that
Professor Celgene mentions that bitcoin
you know displacing a money is something
that is very hard I think it's not as
hard as we as he makes it out to be
hundreds of fiat currencies over the
20th century have been destroyed many
several times over each you know many
currencies were discord several times
and they were replaced by new currencies
or currencies of other countries silver
was demonetized seashells all kinds of
other kinds of money have lost their
monetary role and you know the people
who used to use seashells their network
effect didn't protect them because when
people came into their Island with gold
the harder money won and this is the
dynamic the professor Celgene ignores
bitcoin isn't a startup that needs to do
marketing to attract people bitcoin
isn't going to win because it's going to
you know have a better user experience
or a you know nicer user interface than
your Apple pay or whatever bitcoins
value proposition is that it is hard
money and hard money beats out easy
money and soft money because soft money
and easy money is easy to over produce
and so anytime we look at history and
this is what I discuss extensively in my
book you know when people were using
seashells Europeans arrived they can
make seashells they can dig up for
seashells easily they flood the supply
of seashells seashells lose their
monetary role people use gold and the
same has happened with many other media
and this is essentially the process that
has been going on for the last 10 years
with Bitcoin it's a harder form of money
and it's gaining value because people
would rather hold the harder money than
the easier money and also it's gaining
value because all the easier monies are
being inflated at a much faster rate and
so that really is bitcoins competition
the problem we can always nitpick with
Bitcoin and find things that we think
are wrong with Bitcoin but that is the
alternative that is that is the only
working alternative that
compete with government monies and the
problem with the other currencies that
Professor Celgene mentions and the
problem with any other attempt to try
and compete or to try and introduce a
new monetary standard the problem that
as libertarians I think we people who
probably are a lot of libertarians in
the crowd you know the problem is simply
government won't allow a free-market
monetary system to function because they
want to take it over that's what
happened with a gold system bitcoins
most important most important
characteristic probably other than its
hardness is the fact that it resists
government capture and control because
of the evolution of Bitcoin and this is
something that doesn't share with any of
the other digital coins which are all
centralized because they were all born
after Bitcoin and because you know
they'd never had the they never had the
process of a neutral protocol growing on
the internet on its own without a person
being in charge because the person who
created it disappeared all the other
coins have someone in charge all the
other coins are trivial to compromise
and trivial to capture and therefore
they are not realistic and any ideas of
they are not realistic competitors to
government money they can be easily shut
down so the reason Bitcoin really can
succeed is ultimately because of its
hardness and because of its resistance
the government captured I think those
two things Trump all the other
considerations that Professor Celgene
had mentioned and to go to his points
are saying on the issue of privacy I
think you are giving Bitcoin a little
too much credit bits it's not as good as
you think it is but I don't think that
even matters I think Bitcoin would
function perfectly fine even if every
single coins owner was well-known people
would still own Bitcoin if it meant that
you had to you have to have your
ownership known I think it would still
they use it because I think it's the
hardness that is the value proposition
it's not the privacy in terms of
vulnerability to hacking I think of
course the this is kind of unfair
because Bitcoin is very new and the
people who use the technology are still
learning how to use it so it's natural
that people will have all these growing
pains and of course you know the
infrastructure for handling Bitcoin
better at an individual level and an
institutional level is still in an
infant stage and so also it's not fair
to dismiss Bitcoin
out of hand because you know it's still
at the point where we're developing
those technologies in terms of value
volatility again this is an issue of
maturity Bitcoin has only been around
for ten years and yet it went from just
a bunch of codes written on an email
list to being worth around what two
hundred billion dollars in total right
now which is no joke now 200 billion
dollars is no joke but it's kind of a
joke on a global scale of the in total
Globes money supply it's about 0.2 to
0.3 percent of the world's entire money
supply there are people out there who
own billions of dollars and if one of
them decides to buy a billion dollars
worth of Bitcoin they're going to eat up
the order book in all the Bitcoin
exchanges and that's going to cause the
price to be very volatile because the
liquidity is so small because this thing
is embryonic the size of the order book
the depth of the order book the size of
the liquidity that's available though is
obviously not very large and the size
the people that the size of the money
that wants to go into it is much larger
and so these movements in and out are
likely to have a big effect on the price
but over time as you would expect a bit
going to mature further as you would
expect that the liquidity would grow you
know if it's gone in 10 years from 0 to
200 billion well let's hypothesize that
in another 10 years it goes from 200
billion to 2 trillion which is not that
far of a stretch it's only 10 times but
if it was a 2 trillion dollar market
then it's going to be far less volatile
because then you're going to have a very
deep order book and individual
transactions won't be able to move it
and eventually you know a monitor is a
monetary system a monetary medium gains
stability in its value because of the
fact that it is it has an enormous
number of people selling and buying it
at the same time and so bitcoin doesn't
have that yet but it is building it and
there's no reason to suppose that it
won't be able to build it we're just
witnessing more and more liquidity being
added onto the system and I think this
is going to continue on with respect to
the point 5 on the cost of transacting I
think this completely misses the point
and unfortunately shows that Professor
Celgene did not prepare for this debate
by reading my book and
very disappointed because I've read a
lot of his books and I should say I've
learned a lot from his books and I've
learned a lot from his work but the the
point is that people compare the cost of
Bitcoin transactions to your credit card
transaction or a or you know your bank
transfer and I think that misses the
point because when you're actually
making a payment with a credit card
transaction you're not actually or with
any kind of PayPal or venmo any of those
things yes you're making it instantly
and yes it's very cheap but it's really
just an entry ledger at PayPal that is
says money went from a account a to
account B the actual final settlement of
that transaction takes many more weeks
and what bitcoin transactions are more
comparable to is the final settlement
transactions that happen between central
banks and financial institutions because
those transactions are final you know
that and these transactions take much
longer time to settle than Bitcoin but
we can provide you finality of
settlement across international borders
within a couple of hours well but if you
wanted to send money across
international borders central banks take
many days and weeks to settle payments
between one another one another so
bitcoins payments the base layer of
Bitcoin the on chain transactions cannot
really be compared to individual
consumer transactions because of the
cost but also I think more importantly
there is no such thing as an instant
Bitcoin transaction you should wait at
the very least for two confirmations on
any particular Bitcoin transaction but
it's more advisable to wait for six
confirmations which is about an hour and
that makes it completely unusable as a
commercial payment technology but that's
fine because commercial payment
technology is not a big problem
it's a problem that has been solved by
paypal and venmo and credit cards and
it's the technologies for this are many
and porting them over on top of Bitcoin
is largely a trivial problem we can have
Bitcoin backed credit cards in Bitcoin
backed PayPal and we can have Bitcoin
packed backed venmo
it's pretty straightforward functionally
and there's nothing that prevents it in
other words if you stop thinking of
Bitcoin
payments as compared as being like your
ven mode or PayPal transactions you
realize that PayPal and then will can
function on top of Bitcoin and all of
the features that you don't like about
Bitcoin that you like about venmo can be
essentially ported over to Bitcoin by
replacing the settlement transactions of
a bit of PayPal and then more instead of
them being carried out with Dollars and
fiat currencies they can be carried out
with Bitcoin and so you know does this
introduce reliance on third parties
potentially the Lightning Network is a
solution that is going to minimise the
reliance on third parties but it will
never have the same level of trust
lessness that the on chain transaction
has but that's fine because the
competition for second layer trusted
Bitcoin transactions is not first layer
Bitcoin transactions the competition is
second layer trusted transactions over
highly inflating currencies run by
governments highly sensible and that's
really the key point so don't compare
Bitcoin with your credit card because
your credit card can be added on top of
Bitcoin but a credit or a PayPal or
credit card payment done based on
dollars is inferior arguably to a
Bitcoin based payment because the
Bitcoin is the harder money and that I
think is really the the key value
proposition and so if you compare
Bitcoin to some sort of idea we can
always nitpick about things that are bad
about it but in reality compared to the
real alternatives that exist today
Bitcoin is the only one the only one
that offers is the chance of having a
monetary system free of government
control the only one that offers it's a
chance and I'm not saying it's going to
necessarily happen but there's it can
resist government capture and there's
nothing wrong with its monitor
properties that can make it that would
prevent it from becoming a main medium
of exchange of a country the Bitcoin
supply being fixed is not is not a
disadvantage it is the main advantage
and I would say to people who are
skeptical about it you know we should
think you should think about why is it
that gold became money why isn't it
silver or copper or other mint
became money and that's something I
discuss extensively in my book gold
became money because it is the hardest
metal to who's who supplies the hardest
to increase it's hard that the new
supply of gold every year is tiny
compared to the existing stockpile which
makes it ideal as a monetary unit
because the vast majority of demand and
the back for Bitcoin is monetary and
because the variation in the supply and
variations in the production conditions
are largely irrelevant to the market the
market is largely monetary so Mises
discusses gold as a monetary good and he
says one of the drawbacks of gold is
that it has industrial demand and that
there is variation in its production
because that prevents it from being a
purely monetary good and a purely
monetary good would be a good that is
bought purely for the purpose of being
held as a cash balance and demand for it
is driven by time preference in people's
changes in time preference that's what
an ideal monetary good and Bitcoin in
this regard even improves on gold
because it doesn't have other industrial
uses and that actually makes it even
more suited as a monetary medium for for
for an economy and I think you know the
the test of the market has shown over
the last 10 years Bitcoin has grown
compared to every currency in existence
so the score has been highly favourable
for Bitcoin right now and I don't see
why any reason why things could stop and
I don't see any coherent explanation for
why Bitcoin would is fundamentally
unsuited you know there there might be
problems that happen with Bitcoin
Bitcoin might fail but I think the idea
that it is unsuited is unfounded and I
remain unpersuaded by all the arguments
that Professor solution presented thank
you
five minutes of rebuttal you want to
take the podium five minutes of rebuttal
yes well first of all I let me say that
as much as I like the idea of
privatization of money even if I were to
admit that bitcoin is the only hope for
such privatisation I might still
maintain I would still maintain that
unfortunately it can't cut it and that's
that so those are two different issues
so the fact that it's the only
possibility if we grant that doesn't
prove that it's going to in fact succeed
one of the things I'd like to rebut is
the suggestion that's that safely made
that the fact that the value of
outstanding Bitcoin has gone up so much
is a measure of how much progress it's
making towards becoming widely used
money the capitalization of Bitcoin and
how extensively it's used as a means of
exchange a means of payment are quite
different things they're really mostly
unrelated Bitcoin can be very very
valuable because of the investment
demand being high for it and yet it may
not be used often at all in exchange and
in fact we know that bitcoin is not
widely accepted in exchange for normal
exchanges it has a fairly good demand at
least relative to other uses for
remittances internationally but even
there it faces very stiff competition
from more established remittance means
like Western Union but as a medium of
exchange domestically it is really very
very very small potatoes and the value
of the outstanding stock of Bitcoin
simply doesn't tell you otherwise is
Bitcoin hard money in a sense it is the
absolute amount is limited and in that
sense it resembles gold or some other
precious commodity it has an advantage
over gold and not having a fluctuating
non-monetary demand but there's also a
disadvantage there which is that because
there's no non-monetary demand for
coin there's no basic fundamental demand
for it independent of the demand for it
either for investment speculative
purposes or as a medium of exchange
the reason gold became money and became
so popular as money is because it was
valuable before it became money and that
was a very important reason for its
popularity by the way when gold
displaces wampum that's not proof that a
currency can take place of it take over
and established incumbent money even
though the incumbent money has a larger
Network in fact the gold traders were
coming from big networks and you had two
networks coming together right two
economies that now become in come into
contact with each other the larger
economies network now becomes more
important than the small economies
network so final settlement this is the
most important point I'm afraid I did
read your book I'm afraid you're quite
wrong about final settlement Zell venmo
the real Times payment system that's
just been set up these last two years by
the New York Clearing House Visa
MasterCard these all involve
instantaneous payment clearing and
settlement it's all done instantaneously
whereas with where with Bitcoin even if
you tried to create a sub superstructure
of other payments vehicles on top of it
at bottom those six confirmations have
to take place with all the sluggishness
involved before payment could be final
it's the nature of the blockchain so
there is no way that you will ever have
the speed of final settlement with
Bitcoin or the low expensive
accomplishing it then you can have today
with all kinds of other monies and in
fact you have with most of those monies
and everyone has got to think hard about
what it's going to cost them what it
would cost them to switch to a Bitcoin
standard in their day to day payments
every
you pay for anything you either wait a
long time or you pay a lot or both and
stop thinking about whether the value of
your bitcoins gonna go up and think
about it as a medium of exchange think
about it from the average point of
person's point of view and ask yourself
whether this is likely to be so
attractive that the average person will
want to switch even if it means going
having to not deal with a lot of traders
in the short run I don't think it's
going to happen thank you so professor
Celgene in his reply said two things
that I think the contradiction exposes
the problem with his argument
he said gold became popular as money it
the fact that it was used for industry
and that it was used for jewelry is what
drove demand for it and that's what
allowed it to become popular as money
and that this had a stabilizing effect
on the value of gold and the Bitcoin
without a stabilizing demand other kinds
of demand won't have that stabilizing
effect but then later on he was
describing how the value but but I think
this describes what and then when he
talks about the difference between
Bitcoin as a store of value and a medium
of exchange I think this is opposes that
there is no dichotomy there and there's
no difference in fact the functions of
medium of exchange and store of value
are descriptive functions of the same
thing you can't be a medium of exchange
without storing value because that's you
know and you can't store value without
using something as a medium of exchange
if you're storing value in something
you're going to exchange it at a future
date so it is used as a medium of
exchange so those two things are two
functions to describe the same thing and
the key point is that it is precisely
the fact that the growing and that's the
original point that this is the
contradiction we said you know just
because bitcoin is worth two hundred
nearly a billion dollars doesn't mean
it's being used as money that's exactly
what it means
it means people are using it and they're
holding on to more cash balances with it
and as the cash balances in Bitcoin grow
or as the value of jewelry grows or as
the value of held the gold grows then
the possible opportunities for trade
begin to emerge
more and so now yes within the u.s.
bitcoin is not used but within the
Bitcoin economy on the internet Bitcoin
is already bigger than most national
currencies and so it doesn't have to be
bigger in any one particular country it
just needs to be growing all over the
world and as the demand continues to
grow as people continue to hold it more
as a store of value like this inevitably
means that the opportunities for trading
with others who also hold it as a store
of value would be willing to accept it
or will be willing to use it as payment
these opportunities will likely increase
more and more and so right now you know
200 billion dollars worth of Bitcoin
distributed over let's say 1 million
people around the world that means that
for the mass majority of us it's highly
unlikely that you're gonna want to buy
something from somebody who's willing to
accept Bitcoin at this point but when
Bitcoin is worth two trillion dollars
that equation changes people will have
to spend more of it because they will
need to make payments people will have
to accept as payment will want to accept
it as payment and so really it is the
hardness it is the use of the store of
value that is going to build the cash
balances that would then allow for its
use as as a means of payment more and
more extensively just as was the case
with gold and yes maybe the seashell
network was smaller but remember in the
1860s silver was arguably more widely
used as money than gold up until the
early 1800s China India and Germany
three major economies and much of the US
economy we're using silver as money and
all over the world people are using
silver as money and yet silver was
effectively demonetized by the 1870s
because everybody switched to gold
because gold was a hard there money that
is ultimately what it comes down to and
I see nothing about the problems that
Professor Sam didn't mentions in Bitcoin
that would prevent it from having this
and I think the notion the the the
professor Celgene says you know we are
going to be losing the if you're going
to be he's comparing it to the clearance
that is instant but that is clearance
that is instant and final on the
database of
a government central bank and so you
know if this is not really a free-market
money and that is the problem with it
it's a it's there is no possibility for
having a through free market in an
economy if the one half of every
transaction is controlled and owned by
the government and that really is the
problem with central banking and that is
the problem that Bitcoin solves by
making the final layer of settlement
instead of it being one political
institution controlled by governments it
makes it into a distributed protocol
distributed over thousands of nodes
around the world that cannot change the
monetary policy and cannot be again
cannot use political censorship against
people who are using the technology and
that really is the real value
proposition and I think if you think of
it just purely as a technological tool
it's clearly an example of you know
a bicycle versus a car it's it's its
current monetary systems they're using
you know a centralized system where you
have to basically tell the government
every time you're spending money like
you're a child telling their parents who
keeps tabs on their you know allowance
money and that's an incredibly inferior
system to one in which we don't have to
report to governments in which the final
settlement does not require a government
central bank to handle all of the
clearance and that's really I think
value
[Applause]
well thank you guys and now we get to
the Q&A portion of the evening I want to
start by taking moderators prerogative
to basically clarify a question in my
mind in terms of your exchange I mean we
start with you safe it seems as though
and Jorge can correct me in a moment if
I got him wrong but that Jorge is
basically saying that that there is no
way for Bitcoin transactions to be cheap
and speedy that that that it's simply
inconceivable and so you know we take a
credit card to the store they swipe it
in a moment I mean the old days they
used to look it up in a book they'd look
up the numbers of the book it took a
while and if you old enough to remember
that but now it takes no time and the
expense of the transaction is small and
so it doesn't impede us if our you
didn't are you saying that George is
mistaken to say that transactions such
as you go to the store and you buy
things that those transactions can in in
Bitcoin can indeed be speedy and and
very cheap your tech take them back in
they you can make these transactions
based on Bitcoin and settled Bitcoin at
the back end so in other words the
Bitcoin transaction is better compared
to the final settlement of physical gold
between two central bank's so our
choices before Bitcoin was invented was
either we're going to have essentially
one world government running one central
bank for the world and deciding on
everyone's you know who gets to spend
how much and who can spend money
anywhere or we'd have a neutral
political a politically neutral
international monetary system built on a
neutral asset like gold and the problem
with that of course is that you have to
log gold bars around the world and ship
them and that's expensive and insecure
Bitcoin allows us to do that but instead
of lugging gold bars we send the
transaction that costs a few cents or a
few dollars but the point is the cost of
a Bitcoin transaction could go up to ten
thousand dollars and it would still be a
bargain compared to the final settlement
of physical gold that's what it really
compares to because well you're not
getting any final settlement from your
credit card company or from your banking
for your central bank because it's all
fake money effectively it's all just a
data entry at the Central Bank and the
central bank can take your money away
any moment but bitcoin offers you a hard
asset that is nobody's liability so it's
more comparable to gold settlement
alright but again I'm not clear that you
that you face is you've gone into the
other advantages of Bitcoin as you can
see with them but but again you are
claiming that I can take I think I heard
you say I can take my big Bitcoin Visa
card and and buy some toilet paper at
Walmart and and the transaction will be
very speedy and very cheap well you can
you can sort of do that already because
there are some companies that issue
credit cards that can you can back them
with your do that alright that's fine
okay and and and do I understand you
correctly joy to say that that's can't
happen the criteria for speed of payment
in is how quickly the payment is cleared
and settled in the final payment medium
then all the verification that Bitcoin
requires all the confirmations has to be
have to be completed before the payment
is truly complete yeah and that's what
costs a lot of money it it costs money
because it's a all that computing power
goes into it so basically every
transaction with Bitcoin you you're
paying these fees because of all the
computing power that goes into the
verification which takes time and a lot
of money and that's all going to be
added to the cost of any kind of
payments in a Bitcoin system
you can't evade that with credit cards
because ultimately the verification has
to go through as the final layer of the
final process of the payment whereas
with ordinary money with dollars
we now have ways to do instant payments
on a number of different networks and
they cost practically nothing and the
clearing is done instantaneously it's
true that the final and the clearing and
settlement are done instantaneously it's
true that not all payments but many and
it's getting to the point where it'll be
everything the it's true that the final
settlement often not always takes place
on the books of central banks and so you
do have a trust issue there's no
question about it I'm not denying
that if the proposition where Bitcoin is
the only thing that could take over from
central banks and be absolutely
absolutely non government dependent then
the answer might be yes but that isn't
the proposition the proposition is an
empirical proposition is Bitcoin likely
to actually take over from any
government money the proposition is
whether it is suited suited to okay to
take that it's likely we're not
discussing problem okay fine whether
it's well suited to take over from any
established government money which
requires that ordinary people in large
numbers of them who don't necessarily
consider getting away from government
money as their prime goal will
nevertheless jump on this Bitcoin
bandwagon despite its many disadvantages
including the fact that it's very costly
to transact okay so again that's missing
the point the Bitcoin can do more than
about half a million transactions
currently daily and that's nothing
that's less transactions than happens in
Soho in Manhattan every day probably
well so the notion that we're going to
have all of your transactions on Bitcoin
is a complete non-starter there's only
really any ways but point is those
transactions will be like the final
settlement transaction so instead of
having a global monetary system which
ships 100 international shipments of
gold around the world we can have an
international monetary system that is
built on and half a million Bitcoin
settlement transactions around the world
okay finally
okay in Georgia you're yours the
difference between you again I'm just
picturing the ordinary person going to
Costco Walmart wherever we go and I'm
gonna buy the equivalent of like a
hundred 20 bucks worth of groceries and
and and and and paper and and you're
saying that the cost of that hundred
twenty dollar transaction is going to be
a huge piece of that 120 bucks so that
it's going to be prohibitively expensive
that's what you're saying George yes 120
bucks in less smaller the transaction
the the greater that hundred twenty
bucks
what do you think it's gonna be like 10
percent it's gonna be it's well it's
very difficult to say because part of
the problem is it fluctuates all the
time depending on the computation this
this is all a big misconception because
if your $100 payment to Walmart is not
going to register on chain Walmart is
not gonna wait for six confirmations for
an hour before they give you your
groceries just like the you know if
you're making an international payment
you paying to somebody in China they're
not gonna wait until the central banks
settled the final payment before they
ship you this stuff so in fact the your
grocery payment will be part of
thousands of transactions that will be
settled between your bank and Walmart's
bank in the end of the day and then the
even if it was a thousand dollar
transaction fee for a hundred thousand
transactions probably it is gonna be
worth it that's the key thing if you
think of the final settlement
transaction as a settlement proxying for
many then yeah you're not gonna pay the
transaction fee on $120 the transaction
balance it's it's it's not accurate to
continue to portray this problem and
it's it's a bunch of propaganda that has
plagued Bitcoin because of you know
people who got emotional question only
other questions are you George
I had somebody transfer some Bitcoin to
me just last week just to test this and
in fact for $10 transfer what did it
cost Jeff yeah yeah a dollar for $10
transfer that wasn't hypothetical well
just did it
maybe it's scalable Josh but my question
for you George is this as well let's
imagine that we we have a recurrence of
what occurred in the late 70s even
though worse you know the government the
Treasury debt is ballooning the
government starts pretty outcome and so
it's printing money we we suddenly have
what Greenspan anticipated could happen
around 2030 inflation really heats up
with a dollar the euro is unstable
they're very wobbly so so exactly what
we fear central banks are going to do
which is inflate the currency starts to
happen does that change the ball game at
all from your standpoint with respect to
Bitcoin if that would have happened well
if you have enough national currencies
all going blotto at the same time
telling the Yerba well that still leaves
let's see we've got the franc
other alternative flame to the pound
okay all right those I think that those
would have a better chance than Bitcoin
because they would be less costly all
right but actually I would think the
Canadian dollar would be more convenient
okay you didn't mention that one I
didn't
the canook buck is gonna rule I guess
that's your answer okay well I guess
I'll look forward to that and you do
have an answer for that safe
good luck only a Canadian dollars okay
all right okay okay and guys at any time
you have the opportunity to fire a
question at the other but maybe as
usually happy just a little more serious
answer just you know the path of
government money only heads in one
direction supply increases value drops
and Bitcoin doesn't have that so it's if
it's unsuited for you today you know
let's check back 20 years later when
Bitcoin supply has only gone up about
15% from where it is today whereas you
know government monies have gone up 20x
from where they are today on average and
then imagine the overvaluation that will
happen with Bitcoin compared to good
national currencies and then think about
what you know how easy it will be for
people to get over all of your
objections to Bitcoin when you compare
the devaluation that is happening to the
alternatives okay we I think we have
good questions from the audience because
I think neither if you want to fire a
question at the other at the moment and
so please ask your question ask the
question and tell us who you're
addressing it to if anybody so for for
doctor I must you know one of the one of
the questions was you said the hard
money always drives out the soft money
so gold drives out the seashells and
professor Celgene tried to say that
there's a difference between a store of
value and a medium of exchange and so
this was a misunderstanding on his part
that really in the end there the the
same the the better store value will be
the medium of exchange will win so my
questions about US residential real
estate seems to me it's a very good
store value seems to me there's a lot of
Chinese and Russian billionaires that
agree with me and buy u.s. residential
real estate as a store of value it isn't
a very good medium of exchange in my
opinion so I I'm gonna go have sushi
dinner with my wife we're not gonna pay
with apartment Reid shares when the
check comes we're gonna pay with dollars
it's pretty tradable it's probably less
volatile than Bitcoin don't you think
does it do you really not believe
there's a difference between do you
always think the hard money drives out
the good the gold is harder money than
the dollar but we use dollars not gold
for for paying for things you're cute
are you gonna stick on this point it
seems to me professor soldiering makes a
really good case I'm gonna stick to it
because actually the only reason we
still use dollar the fact is that all
the central banks in the world still
continue to hold gold if we're using
dollars they just dump all of their gold
on the market and that would be the end
of it but they don't because the only
reason their money and you know they
don't trust each other's paper they
realize that the paper can be inflated
to no end and therefore they only hold
gold amongst themselves that's the first
point to go back to your original
question functionally speaking yes when
you when you store value in your house
you are also in a sense functionally
using it as a medium of exchange but of
course the house is a crappy medium of
exchange and sorry excuse my language
but it's also very bad a store of value
because it's you know obviously it's
good because it's hard it's harder to
make more houses it's harder to inflate
the supply but as you said it's very
hard to pay with you know a chunk of
your house when you need it and it's not
liquid and it takes a lot of time to
sell and you know moving in and out of a
house is very expensive and very costly
but the reason people are using real
estate as a store of value the people
the reason we have endless real estate
bubbles endless art bubbles endless
bubbles in everything is because people
are using all of these instruments like
stocks and real estate and art as a
store of value because we are legally
banned from having a good money we are
not allowed to have a free market money
because government restricts the Mavi
market for money through central bank
monopoly which means that as an
individual if you want to hold money you
need to hold money that is liquid across
the world today so you want to hold
dollars or your national currency
because you need to pay with it and or
if people outside the US you know they
need to hold their national currency
they need to hold the dollar if they
want to pay abroad and if they would
like to hold something that will hold
value across time they need to hold gold
or real estate or so on and so as a
result we need to use several things as
a store of value and as a medium of
exchange because we don't have the one
good thing that would do this job there
was no real estate bubble happening on
the gold standard because people weren't
using their houses as a store of value
if you wanted to store value you bought
gold if you wanted a house you bought a
house I bought some you George or do you
want to pass the question you want to
comment or you want to pet there were
some real estate bubbles under the gold
standard when well for one thing in the
1920s was a man that was not under the
gold standard it certainly was no the
gold Snider was suspended in 1914 and it
was the suspension of the gold standard
that led to the depression in 1929 they
were back on gold they were bad she said
it was a crappy gold standard I thought
you that was your big point Joe so also
the crisis was they went off the gold
standard to print money in the 1920s
okay we're gonna we're not gonna resolve
that one next question primary doctor I
moose my understanding is that in order
to transact a Bitcoin like a single
$10,000 Bitcoin the thousands of
participants have to solve some
mathematical algorithm which requires a
lot of computation
Yuuka hashes whatever those are and this
is getting very expensive is it seems to
me that the want the whole Bitcoin
transaction procedure kind of strangle
itself by just becoming so expensive
that we can't afford to do these
computations anymore is the Soho for I'm
going to become so popular that we can't
fit people into the place and then it's
no longer functions if it becomes
popular you know it's not gonna fail
because of too much demand I think
that's just a misunderstanding of how
economics works if people are demanding
the transactions and the value of the
transactions going up and Bitcoin
continues to refuse to die as we've been
getting told by a friend in full four
years that that's what's going to happen
because of transaction fees perhaps it's
time to revisit your priors and think
about whether actually cheap
transactions is the point of Bitcoin in
fact it's yeah it's gonna require more
and more energy and it's gonna become
more and more expensive but it's gonna
procs each more you know it's gonna
proxy for more and more transactions so
it'll actually be
cheaper per transaction over time as
more and more people continue scalable
yeah coming from you George do the
question would you want to pass and go
to next okay next person yeah what do
you think is gonna be an impact of
regulations and why do you think that
bitcoin is cannot be confiscated by the
government
well there were a number of cases when
if coins were confiscated and when they
facing life sentences recently probably
might three call your private the key is
pretty fast I guess it's a challenge to
save so I guess safety will have you
will have you come in I'm I wouldn't say
it can to be confiscated I just say that
it's much harder to confiscate than say
gold because gold requires physical
settlement and clearance which ends up
because of the economies of scale
involved ends up with you know one
central bank in every country and so
taking over gold was trivial in 1934 for
the US government because they just
banned the banks from using gold and
they took over the gold that was already
in the banks it's much harder with
Bitcoin because instead of having one
central bank you're gonna have thousands
of nodes and so it's you know I'm not
saying it will or it won't happen we'll
have to watch and see but it has a much
better chance of resisting capture than
gold does comment George I've tried to
steer clear from the the question of
what governments might or might not do
because it's of course possible that
governments could themselves interfere
with Bitcoin and make it less likely to
succeed but I don't want to appeal to
that possibility in this debate because
I don't think it's really the relevant
question don't vote for Georgia and that
basis is what he's saying to you so the
next question yes for professor Celgene
of the three monies discussed tonight
commodity money which is gold fiat money
which is issued by governments and free
market digital money Bitcoin we know
historically why the first two or how
the first two were adopted as money
we're watching Bitcoin struggle to be
adopted as money as you your position
seems to be can you articulate a path
that any new money of any form would
need to take in order to be adopted as
money
and how can you be sure that the path
Bitcoin is on is not taking the path of
least resistance for some brand new
money yeah that's a good question the
the fact is that once you know Menger to
talk a little bit about the theory here
for me
carl menger the Austrian founder of the
Austrian school developed the most
famous theory of the origins of money
which explained how you could get
commodity money from a situation where
there was no generally used medium of
exchange and so fascinating theory that
same theory also explains the network
problem that is it points to the fact
that once something is established as a
generally accepted medium of exchange in
any community it's very difficult for
something else to them get established
the horserace having been run it's very
difficult for anything so I'm not
actually when I emphasize them the
network problem and not really trying to
say this is a prop that's a problem for
Bitcoin it's a problem for any upstart
currency and so they're all equally at a
disadvantage in that regard but then the
point is if such an upstart is going to
try to get a leg up and it can under the
right circumstances where the incumbent
currency is distrusted depreciating
there are many things that could make it
make tempts people to take the risk of
joining a smaller network and taking
their chances with it but then it's a
question of how relatively attractive
the upstart is compared to the incumbent
it has to be fairly attractive in a lot
of dimensions and that's where I think
Bitcoin suffers because in some crucial
respects it has real disadvantages
compared to other potential alternatives
including gold by the way which hasn't
come up enough in this context I think
people will be more likely to use gold
in an emergency would say the the euro
and the dollar and the Canadian dollar
etcetera are all going to plop that gold
might have
better chance of taking off than Bitcoin
because despite its clear transactions
cost of moving it around between it and
claims to it it could have advantages
compared to bit that Bitcoin lacks you'd
mentioned cryptocurrency George you
still cryptocurrency that you could like
or do like aside from Bitcoin I won't
mention particular names there are that
it's so experimental at this point that
there are some others that I think have
advantages I will say that the second
most popular aetherium has some of the
same disadvantages as Bitcoin as far as
transaction cost I think that it has
roughly can handle roughly twice as many
transactions that's not a big difference
so it also has that that problem of high
of a scalability disadvantage but some
of the others may be better'n on those
at that and other grounds a distributed
network is going to inevitably be less
efficient than a centralized network if
you're gonna have one computer with a
backup record the transaction it's much
easier so on my laptop there's software
that I could download that would allow
me to run fifteen thousand transactions
per second you know I could run a
payment network on my laptop and do
fifteen thousand transactions per second
it's trivial the problem is my laptop is
not very reliable and so you're not
gonna build an international monetary
system on my laptop
however ten thousand laptops connected
to one another is going to be very slow
and very cloudy and very inefficient but
it's reliable as and it's more reliable
than anything else it's really reliable
and so the notion that we are going to
continue to judge cryptocurrencies by
their speed is completely I think
misplaced it's not it's never going to
be able to scale to a scale that allows
us to have mass consumer payments it's
out of the question and you know we've
had a few experiments with some of the
altcoins they forked bitcoins code and
they made the Bitcoin with a bigger
block size and now nobody uses it and
the coins are dying a painful slow death
and it's just proof that this thing is
not gonna be used for mass consumer
payments it's never gonna work now I
have to ask my question okay
which is how can something be the main
medium of exchange of any economy and
not be used for mass consumer payments
these are the same thing it's really
hard that you're missing the distinction
between something being used as a medium
of exchange and something being used as
a means of payment so in order to
simplify this if I make a payment to
Professor Celgene right now with PayPal
what is the medium of exchange that we
used the dollars yes not PayPal PayPal
is the method of payment and the be cash
people have made this such a big
misunderstanding with all of the
propaganda that they've done that people
have missed the distinction when you're
making a payment with PayPal you're
using PayPal as the method of payment
but the medium of exchange is a dollar
and no actual physical dollars were
harmed in the making of that payment so
at the end of the week or the month my
bank and your bank will settle with one
another and you know there might
actually be physical gold moving around
between a physical money moving around
between the banks and the central banks
but we have to understand the
distinction between the settlement layer
and the consumer layer and so continuing
to compare Bitcoin to the consumer layer
misses the point because there's no way
Bitcoin will ever handle one percent of
the transaction that visa can handle
Visa is just always going to be much
faster than Bitcoin but that's fine it's
a completely different engineering
problem and so these are PayPal all of
those things can are completely
orthogonal to Bitcoin dollar gold and
Bitcoin that's bitcoins competition
these are PayPal and so on they compete
with a lightning Network as settlements
as payment solutions so there can be
Visa PayPal bitcoins what you're saying
okay yeah our next question thank you
both for this fantastic
check out saves book it's fantastic to
either of you there's talk about
clearance settlement if I were to take
my dollars out of my bank account and
put those in my safe in my house I now
have those I mean those those are
settled and cleared right in other words
I own those is that right I mean could
you guys perhaps speak to this idea of
final settlement and clearance because
in my mind there is no such thing as
final settlement with a fiat currency
because at any point in time
take the indian $20 take the 1933 gold
confiscation i mean there is no such
thing as final settlement so the time to
settle in a US dollar is i don't think
it ever occurs and so in that regard I
think Bitcoin settles at an exceedingly
faster rate and perhaps you could speak
to that thanks safe agrees with what you
just said yeah do you agree too George
oh I don't agree no there really is such
a thing as final settlement it's I mean
it's two different things here one is
whether the government can grab your
stuff that's one issue the other is
whether it's such a thing as final
settlement in the dollar Fiat system and
there is and it occurs when the when the
actual that when actual ownership of
base dollars which are either cash or or
credit balance on the in the reserve
account at the Federal Reserve Bank has
made its way to the bank that handled
the transaction and that's finished when
no one knows when no one owes anything
anymore then it's final that's that's a
great way of putting it when nobody owes
anybody anything anymore then in the
transaction has settled but that's not
the case with your paypal payment it
takes much longer for it to settle and
so that's why that's what bitcoin is up
against it's up against the bank's
settling with one another in the central
bank settling with one another and as as
he mentioned the effect of real
settlement time in fiat is infinite
because you never know ten years later
you can come and take your money they
don't have to come and take your money
your money is there so you just have you
know they let you take it out
and then occasionally but if it's
effectively government money and
government can confiscate it at all
times so bitcoin is a massive
improvement in that regard because it
allows us the access to base money to be
far more widely distributed and
decentralized and available for more
people next question hi thank you both
professor you said in your opening that
because centralized exchanges have been
hacked somehow that makes Bitcoin the
network vulnerable to hack considering
Bitcoin the network has an uptime of
ninety nine point six percent I'm just a
little confused how the two are related
you said that because the centralized
exchange roping statement you said the
centralized exchanges have been hacked
which is true I think we're all aware of
many you know hackings that have
happened somehow that makes Bitcoin the
network vulnerable to hack as well but
my question is considering that Bitcoin
the network has an uptime of 99 percent
I'm just a little bit confused have one
however had their equitable well I never
said that the Bitcoin network was
vulnerable I only said that the
exchanges were vulnerable but that's
where a lot of people keep keep their
money much of the time so the the
question is whether the storage
facilities are vulnerable compared to
the storage facilities for established
monies like the dollar which would be
banks and that was the comparison I made
that's different from network
vulnerability and I've readily concede
that finally this unfortunate he's gonna
have to be the final question of the
evening I'll be very quick then say if I
saw you speak about two years ago and I
wrote at the time that you gave the most
plausible case for the mass adoption of
Bitcoin that I've ever heard and I agree
that it continues to be I also wrote at
the time that you characterized it as
inevitable I didn't hear that tonight
and I'm wondering whether I
misunderstood at the time or whether
you've lowered the probability in your
mind if it happening I've got an older
and I've got more gray hair and I've
learned to be less certain about things
in life to the kids who acted on your
advice thick that's funny
all right through it yeah yeah the
resolution is just has to do with
suitability and neither side is talking
about inevitability George is saying
that nothing's inevitable with either of
these guys so we've clarified that
suitability not inevitability is the
resolution I will give it one front one
final question yeah so my question is do
you think that the portion of Bitcoin
that is used as a speculative asset is
significant and how would it affect it
becoming a medium of exchange I think
all bitcoins are used as speculative
assets and that's fine money is a
speculative asset and you know
speculation gets a bad rep because you
know it's always blamed by governments
you know whenever inflation happens it's
always because of the speculators and
the evil foreigners or whatever but
really speculation is what you do every
moment of your life you're speculating
on economic activities and you're making
decisions on it and holding money is a
speculative act because the only reason
as Mises explains the only reason people
hold money is because of uncertainty
life is uncertain and therefore you have
to hold money because you don't know
what you're going to be doing or what
you need to spend in the future so in
that sense you know Bitcoin being
speculative me holding Bitcoin
speculatively is no different than
holding dollars or anything else it
speculatively you hold it so that you
can exchange it in the future for
something else and you hope that you can
get a lot for it it's no different when
you do it with dollars and bitcoin is
just Bitcoin is you know it's going
through the process of monetization at a
very fast rate so at this point Bitcoin
can be better thought of I think as sort
of like a seed investment in a startup
that is planning to replace all of the
world's central bank and you this
startup is a sort of a self-organizing
spontaneous startup that you know
instead of shares it has the own Bitcoin
coins and instead of having a management
it just has a bunch of algorithm that
will take the value that would issue new
coins and provide it to the people who
secure the network and you know it's
just this random and not random this
spontaneously emergent organization
that's going to eat all the central
banks of the world and if you buy a
Bitcoin right now
effectively you're feeding that monster
and you're speculating on the monster
growing further so it is it is more of a
speculative asset than just money right
now but that's fine that's how we're
gonna have to eat central banks George
you want to respond with your party's
summation okay five minutes of summation
or do you want to insist on an answer Oh
take you to the podium with your five
minutes for summation is all right all
right it's good okay I was going to say
very briefly that all monies are
speculative as as I said but some of
them are more risky than others and that
I say is the difference between Bitcoin
in a lot of established money's but it's
by way of summary I guess all I really
want to insist upon is the fact that
when when ordinary people when ordinary
people which excludes many of you when
ordinary people think what should I
watch what what what kind of money do I
want to equip myself with what what
should I use as a medium of exchange the
answer again first of all is what's
everybody else using what if there's a
store down the street take what what do
my workers want to get paid in these are
the the mundane issues that are asked
and they speak of the importance of
established network size but beyond that
they ask how risky is this stuff going
to be to have on hand all the time do I
risk losing a large percent of the value
just while I'm waiting to do my shopping
is it going to fluctuate a lot do I have
to make all kinds of elaborate plans to
protect myself finally they're going to
ask every time I shop with this how long
is it going to take for my payment to be
complete and what's it going to cost me
how they're gonna is there gonna be a an
art substantial fee extracted from every
payment to cover the costs of
verification etc do I have to pay extra
if I want it done quickly if I
sure the payee that the money is going
to be there on time these are the
questions people ask and if their aunt
and if the answer is that an established
currency is more attractive on many of
these scores than an upstart the upstart
has no chance if the answer is that the
established currency isn't all that
attractive but there are other
currencies with large networks that
might be used instead they're going to
have a better chance than that new
currency and for all these reasons
bitcoins odds its suitability if you
prefer since we're talking about that
its suitability to take over as the main
currency of any country is very very
poor I hope the private marketplace will
come up with new alternatives
potentially new cryptocurrencies that
beat Bitcoin in many of these respects
and make for a better alternative to
established fiat money's but if we stop
now if we say Bitcoin or bust I think
it's going to be bust
I mean ultimately I think I was some up
and say that you know the the Freudian
slip fascist Alton said about you know
the odds it's still thinking of it in
terms of probability and I think you
know he hasn't provided anything in
terms of the actual suitability that
could sway somebody to change their mind
on this I think we went over the points
and I don't think you know the cost of
transacting is not an issue because it's
not you're not going to be paying that
transaction fee that transaction is
going to be divided over many thousands
of transactions the volatility is purely
a function of the size and I think the
same as in terms of the liquidity
available in what is the neighboring
grocery store using I see these as
purely functions of bitcoins nation's
bitcoins use and I would have imagined
six years ago
for instance if somebody had told me yet
this thing is never gonna take o take
over I think it might have made more of
a compelling case because at that point
you know Bitcoin was worth a few hundred
million dollars or whatever but now
we've seen it grow so much and we've
seen how it has been able to handle that
growth we've seen how you know security
continues to work even as it grows and
you know that there's nothing to suggest
that it would stop functioning as it
grows and then there is that means that
basically there's there's no compelling
reason why it wouldn't be suitable and
the fact is Professor Selden goes back
to talking about people's choices in
this and whether people will choose it
or not but that again is irrelevant to
the suitability and ultimately the
choice of money is not a democracy you
know we don't get together and decide we
want to use you know silver as money or
gold as money or seashells as money it's
cold hard economic reality that imposes
it use a store of value that is easy to
inflate and you will not have any value
left so it's not even about your choice
because if you choose badly you just
don't have any more money left and then
only the people who chose wisely have
money left and that's how hard money
works that's how gold drove out all the
many other pretenders and the people who
had that money you know their vote about
whether they like gold's color whether
they prefer Silver's color whether they
prefer the network effect of their local
seashells doesn't matter anymore gold
one because they stored their wealth in
an easy money and that easy money was
inflated and professor Celgene is I
think is missing the fact that this is
what is happening all over the world you
know with negative interest rates and
with the inflation around the world it's
just becoming harder and harder for
people to be able to store value in
their money in their national currencies
and so bitcoin is um is essentially
winning by default right now because
nothing else is even trying to be a
store of value because the world is full
of Keynesian who think that store of
that use a bad thing and that you know
people shouldn't have a store of value
because you know the government knows
what they should invest in or whatever
so in a sense bitcoin is already winning
in this regard it is already growing and
I don't see anything compelling to
suggest and I think the the suggestion
that you know hopefully other
cryptocurrencies come about is you know
it's it's been used to promote many
thousands of cryptocurrencies but none
of them has introduced any thing at all
that Bitcoin cannot do there isn't a
single currency other than Bitcoin that
has done anything that Bitcoin can do
yet and you know we hear so many
promises and so many ideas but I think
the key point is this as Professor
Celgene is one of the foremost scholars
who's written on money being free and on
the free market and money I think the
point is in terms of suitability I think
it's clear that it is suitable it's
already more suitable than most national
currencies because it's already an
economy much larger than most national
currencies and the reality is this is it
this is the only chance we have of a
free market money we can argue
theoretically in like you do in some of
your papers about possible better models
for bitcoins monetary policy maybe days
are indeed better maybe you know having
a money the supply that grows at 2% is
better I don't think it is but you know
even conceding that it is doesn't really
matter at this point because that money
is not going to come about we're not
going to have a central bank implement
an algorithmic rule it can't be
implemented it can always be overrun
we're not going to be able to develop
something that is completely trustless
anymore bitcoin was really a truly
one-off experiment that can't really
easy to be repeat
and it doesn't need to be all of the
people that are just constantly finding
problems with Bitcoin need to just come
to peace with it this is your only
alternative to central bank's deal with
it well thank you guys for a very
spirited debate very lively and done you
both behaved like ultimate gentlemen so
you're both won tonight in that sense a
very important sense we now want to open
the final vote which you've done Jane
opened the final vote again the
resolution is Bitcoin is poorly suited
to the purpose of becoming any nation's
main medium of exchange both sides were
dressing suitability that word said
ability very important and so where do
we send like okay we've got the final
vote well okay poorly suited it is
poorly suited to be a main medium of
exchange the pre vote was thirty nearly
35 percent on that that was in favor of
the resolution it gained a little over
seven points to 41 percent so that's the
number to beat
George gained seven points on the other
hand the no vote went from 28 percent to
50 percent so safe picked up 22
percentage points safe against the
trophy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]